hi and welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons and Sony Pictures
Entertainment just released the newest
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer and boy does this trailer have a
lot and when I say a lot I mean a lot I
mean it has a worried Rio a Nexus Hub of
different spideys and all these clashes
with no sight of the two-part villain
spot what's going on I'm gonna take the
deepest plunge into this trailer and
spot all the Easter eggs you might have
missed and let me tell you this took
some serious digging we're all taking
this trailer as a team so as to divide
and conquer so keep a watch out on
bosses and mt's breakdown as well let's
just get into it right now with my
Easter egg breakdown we opened the
trailer to the Sony logo which flashes
and glitches between Ben day dots and
RGB colors if you look closely we start
getting a more peculiar design we get
the look of a comic book panel with the
comic design resembling an Archie comic
book designed for the Columbia Pictures
we get the Marvel logo with blue paint
edging out of the lines we've already
started getting the taste of different
art styles that will be ushered
throughout the movie and what we see
later in this trailer miles is on a
rooftop overlooking the New York skyline
now this scene probably takes place
after this shot that was a newly
released image a couple weeks ago seeing
as his mom and him are wearing the same
outfits I think they're under the water
tower Rio discusses her worries as miles
is growing and no longer needing her as
she speaks we start getting flashbacks
from 2018's into the spider-verse it's
important moments from the movie that I
like to add like him receiving the
costume from Stan Lee learning the flip
with Peter B Parker falling for Gwen and
his leap of faith also look at all that
sweet sweet representation with the
Puerto Rican flag also good to note that
this is a newer suit than what we saw in
the last movie also just want to know
there's a block party going on soon
Fourth of July is so keep that in mind
as an event probably expected to be
ruined by the spot when miles takes the
hot dog I like the little title that
says take like in the first movie with
the bagel toss when it popped up bagel
and he sticks some money to his tummy
with the Spidey web and money signs all
above it when we get back to Miles
bedroom his room is decked out they got
the anti-social Social Club parody
poster ASAP Rocky's long live ASAP album
poster a parody of course this poster
says the way of the butterfly with what
I think is Muhammad Ali and top skater
on Playstation with Spider-Man on it you
know it's just like a young man's room
and I love it that's when we start
getting those same colors from the
opening of the trailer the glitches and
Bubbles start dissolving the space and
objects start to float around the room
it's actually really beautiful now it
sort of resembles the ending of into the
spider-verse but notice how the features
on his face have gone longer his frame
is taller I think he's grown since we
last seen him so there's a possibility
that Miles and Gwen have been able to
meet a couple of times since we last saw
them and into the spider-verse only the
movie can tell for certain but I think
it's a green light the comic next to
Miles head floating is the same comic
from into the spider-verse that gets
stuck to his hand the true life Tales of
Spider-Man we also know the 42 symbolism
is in honor of Jackie Robinson what
could be a little added hint to them
visiting is Gwen in this cardigan just a
quick little visit might be brisk in an
alternate universe you know what I'm
saying it's also worth noting that in
the first look trailer we got a while
ago the spider Gwen looks identical to
this spider Gwen they just edited out
the flying objects in the cardigan
probably because they didn't want it to
get out that this probably isn't Gwen's
first first time visiting you let me
know what you think in the comics but I
think this stands now we've seen these
hexagons in the first trailer and it's
revealed when miles whips through one
it's allegedly moonboten so each hexagon
could represent Another Universe we also
know in one division they had a ton of
hexagons but seeing as this is Sony and
not the MCU I'll just leave that there
right when Rio his mother says wherever
you go from here you have to promise to
take care of that little boy for me
we're taken to literally like the
Citadel of Rick's but for Spider-Man in
this universe Spider-Man are existing
and hanging out say from any harm so we
think and The Amazing Spider-Man issues
9 and 10 Earth 13 was a safe zone so
maybe we're looking at something like
that for this Citadel also known as Gwen
shoes they've changed from her normal
Flats to these Chucks it was announced
at the trailer after party that these
actually belong to Hobie voiced by
Daniel Kalua and they have a close
relationship to one another that makes
miles a little jealous makes sense since
they're both punk as hell and rock out
how are they hanging out though and I'll
get into that in a moment I'm on camera
a lot so I have to see my face a lot so
you think I have to put a lot of effort
in my skincare routine but I don't
because I use geology
here it is geology is a 15-time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000
five-star reviews that's more than I can
count on one hand and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you gotta do
is take a 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology figures out your routine for you
which is very hard to do normally so
thank you geology if you need Hair Care
use geology's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
build up and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoos and for the rest of
your shower routine you can use their
body washes which are free of harsh
ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c e feralic serum
to keep your skin looking young and
healthy and then a bit of dermatologist
tested aluminum free deodorant that
quite honestly smells great and I have
sensitive pits so they're amazing right
now for a limited time geology is
hooking our audience up with an
absolutely insane offer if you use code
new rockstars you will get an additional
70 off their award-winning skincare
trial set that discount applies whether
you're stocking up for yourself or
stuffing someone else's stockings
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all your favorite geology
products to get started just click the
link in the description take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door this is
where I'll just get into all this
fighties and then we'll come back to the
trailer in its normal order firstly
there's a ton of Spiderman here and some
I don't think have that much importance
or they just made them with different
colors to show how many Spider-Mans
there really are in the universe so I'll
go over a good chunk of them and let me
know if I missed any behind Gwen and
Miles we see a bunch of classic looking
spidermen and this classic Spider-Man
suit that genuinely could just be anyone
but the white spider logoed one I'm
assuming is from Spider-Man velocity
when you zoom out we see everyone's
favorite most anticipated now since
knowing Insomniac Spiderman and Miles
Morales we've actually also seen that
Insomniac Spiderman suit before and into
the spider-verse beside them seated is
the Mark II Bulletproof roof armor from
Amazing Spider-Man issue 656 from 1999
the Spiderman they're talking to is hard
to pinpoint and I knew rockstars we kind
of teamed up on it and we think this
could be a white suit from 2099 up to
the left this could be any Spider Woman
but I'm placing bets on May Parker
walking alongside her was also very hard
to pinpoint we started getting very
frustrated but ultimately this could be
Foundation Spidey suit but I also think
we could see Foundation Spidey suit
later when we zoom out a bit more we see
the renew your valve Spider-Man which
Spider-Man MJ and their daughter all
have Spider-Man Powers top left we get
the manga vs Spider-Man spider cop from
Earth 19119 we see the iron spider suit
from the civil war comics Spider-Man in
his negative suit lady spider AKA
Maybelle Riley she's actually one of my
favorites she's very fun please read her
comics beside her is undie Spider-Man no
I think this is undie Spider-Man because
that looks like a snake at Spider-Man
now we see a normal Spider-Man suit and
I believe they're talking with the fear
itself suited Spidey from the PS4 game
above that we see a more different
fitted Spidey suit but I think the blue
one is April Parker from earth982 also
at the top I think we've got another
variation of Jessica Drew Spider Woman
we get the bombastic Bag Man suit
Spider-Man that had no mask and the
Human Torch lent his suit but he had to
use a paper bag to cover his face
probably because of legal reasons that's
why they're not using the Fantastic Four
suit we got the werewolf Spidey there's
a spidey with a Letterman's jacket and I
think this is Flash Thompson with the
hair sticking up out of the costume
something worth noting is every
Spider-Man has a bracelet from the first
look trailer we know that Miguel uses
this to jump universes so these
bracelets might have been given or
created by almost every Spider-Man I say
almost because technically we don't know
how miles got his in this movie I think
this was given by Miguel because in the
trailer After Party they said in regards
to Gwen you get invited into Oscar
Isaac's cool spider Force you get
invited to miles does it and you sort of
can't tell him why let me know what you
think in the comments because I think
this could be tied to Miles living in
the universe that originally had a
Spider-Man and that former Spider-Man
was the representative for that Universe
I also think Hobie is a member of spider
force and that's how he met Gwen we see
our Amazing Spider Woman and now this is
fun better woman voiced by Issa Ray you
can see her little baby bump in the
trailer she's fighting pregnant baby
this is insane you see her spider webs
also come out of her fingertips instead
of like a machine or her like wrist
wrist now it looks like they're pulling
from the 2015 Spider Woman where she is
indeed pregnant but also a private
investigator also it's worth noting the
homage to our first Spider Woman I just
love that the afro is just not fitting
underneath the mask so just wear the
eyes it's whatever and the comic she
also has a motorcycle she's ridden one
even in the spider Gwen issues so maybe
this is pre-baby motorcycle riding Jess
before she has to put it away for good
she's fighting the vulture and the art
design for the vulture is
um I I eat this up it looks so good like
some Da Vinci work Voss will get into
this design more in the breakdown so
please anticipate the design breakdown
from boss later on we moved to the scene
of all the Spider-Man jump in our Spidey
and for why we have a superior
Spider-Man aka the doc off a symbiote
Spider Girl top left that could be the
AI effect Spider-Man or tarantula from
Earth 1610 there's actually a ton of six
limit spideys so it could be any of them
we have armored Spider-Man from 94 also
a business Spider-Man and a business
little suit what is he doing we get what
could be Scarlet Spider 2 suit from the
video games flipping in the far left we
also have Jessica Drew we have the
spider monkey which oh my God he's
probably my favorite we have the
PlayStation one Spider-Man everyone has
called this out online you can tell by
its design this white hooded Spider-Man
looks more like the 2099 white suit of
Spidey which is Miguel but it has a hood
so this could be a generic Spidey from a
different colder Universe now let's jump
to the scene where we get a glimpse of
our Cape Spidey AKA Spider-Man Unlimited
from back in the day we also see the
Scarlet Spider AKA Ben Riley now we see
our favorite Spidey from into the
spider-verse return Peter B Parker
voiced by Jake Johnson sporting a robe
but also a baby sleep
we know from the YouTube premium q a
after the trailer release we're going to
see a baby May which we can assume is
probably this Peter's baby safe to
assume once he went home and into the
spider-verse he rekindled everything
with MJ and lost a little bit of weight
but I liked you either way you look good
both ways he's also walking upside down
in what looks like the same place we see
Gwen and Miles earlier in the trailer
you can see this machine in the
background which I suspect is
two that I think is an alchemex we get
an over-the-shoulder shot of Miguel
O'Hara looking at an image of him and
what we can assume is probably his
daughter which will probably be the
major motive for him in this movie if I
had to guess whatever he's trying to fix
has directly affected him in his past
life with his daughter in the comics
Miguel has a son Gabriel named after his
brother and in this movie it looks like
his daughter will be Gabriella the file
is named gabriella011 and as we know
unfortunately in Spider-Man's Life Death
is not far behind so she probably passed
away this solemn shot could mean a lot
of things but I think it's worth noting
how Miguel's head is turned suggesting
it's time to go Jessica looks super
apologetic I like the idea that Jessica
is playing up the role of the private
investigator she's also helping Miguel
and they're working as a team deadline
reported the friendship and footage seen
at cinemacon so this might be true now
like I said earlier there's sort of
spider Force going on I assume the
Spider Woman is also on that team now in
the trailer After Party they say the
cool thing about Gwen she has a special
relationship with Jess because she sees
her as a potential Mentor someone who
seems to have it all figured out which I
think will be a great dynamic because
they're two badasses but this spider
Force is furthering this notion of
teamwork friendship group ascieties when
miles only had Gwen Peter B Parker and
the others and into the spider-verse
it's like seeing your best friend get
other best friends and you also have a
crush on that best friend you know it is
just hard this spot resembles the spot
at the end of into the spider-verse
teaser that we got these webbed hexagons
look like spider was but also resemble
brain neurons and I think this is inside
a giant computer Miguel's to be exact we
see an unmasked Miguel O'Hara and our
boy is jacked oh he's big as hell in my
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
updates video I made a suggestion since
we're going into Miguel's Universe he
lives in a timeline where Alco Max has
taken over this is where Doc Ock AKA Liv
was working into the spider-verse a lot
of people have also speculated that this
machine might be the portal that people
use to get into the Spider-Man universe
so that's good but if it's the bad one
in alcamex it's bad I'm sure it's one of
the two we get this close-up of spider
Gwen and it's actually breathtaking the
colors and illustration Styles the
signature of someone's initials on her
cheek like a true still from a
storyboard I think this is one we can
expect for all hell to break lose seen
as the Styles change aggressively like
it's falling apart we also see Gwen from
the looks of it saving an airplane a
whale looks like an airplane tail I'm
gonna go with airplane right then we get
Gwen's narration we're supposed to be
the good guys we get the shot of
Miguel's Universe in way of a York and
the Sid meat style art that comes with
it the archway to the futuristic tunnel
says follow the speed limit clearly
Miguel is not check out that speed on
that boy also note how the top right
corner it says Imperial Violet crimson
red like this is a piece straight from a
storyboard and I love this attention to
detail when he whips to smash miles down
I like that this could go two ways his
suit is peeling away maybe because he
shouldn't be in that universe or he's
literally getting the clothes knocked
off of him there's also a ton of things
that we didn't actually get to see in
this trailer we know we'll be seeing
Daniel kalua's hobby AKA spider pun
pavitier our Spider-Man from India May
the baby and we didn't even get a look
at the spot our villain now normally I'd
get into these characters especially the
ones we didn't see but later this week
or next week my video breaking down each
prominent Spider-Man from across the
spider verse will include information
about all these folks missing from the
trailer that's everything that I found
in this trailer there's a ton of new
information and I know I tried my
hardest hitting each one though there
was a ton of information we didn't
actually get a full glimpse of the full
story so there's a million theories we
can still make and we shall follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]